so we're hearing Poznan Poland and it's
Cicero's recipes last day here with us
we've had three wonderful days together
with Luke Calipari a mother as well
speaking in a number of different
languages and one thing I thought would
be really useful to talk about is
something that you wrote a book on
susana and that's the connection between
language of music right don't talk a lot
about your book and how and how you see
language and music and their symbiotic
yeah sure so the connection to language
and music is that language and music in
the brain occupy similar parts of the
brain but also they have places in the
brain where they're not activated in the
same place so music can actually be used
to reactivate language functions and we
can see that right now with in the
United States representative Cabrillo
Giffords who was shot in the head year
and a half ago and she's working with
the music therapist to regain her verbal
abilities and I learned about this by
reading what called musical failure by a
British neurologist Oliver Sacks he's
the same one who wrote awakenings that
this movie that was made in was made
into a movie with Robin Williams and
Robert DeNiro and he talked about how
music affects the brain and how music
activates more parts of the brain the
language to us and I realized that I
listen to languages like music so I pick
up on the ups and downs of language the
intonation the stresses but also I
listen to a lot of foreign language
music and that helps in our languages
and the other part that I think that is
missing in the school system or any many
epidemic in my
two languages is that when you learn a
language you have to give yourself up to
the language in Spanish say look I can
do you guys sell my language no waitomo
in unless escuelas nothing senior I'll
go to lug nuts it's Enya okay I keep the
neighbors only oh I will cover la do la
grammatic I come over some pero I can
trigger say a glioma hilo castle la
música okay no sort of indicate if I'm a
Spartan okay love pero las Activa and
even he was from na VI que tener I did
know that and that I was not gonna get
yo but casino Vivian wasn't a sensitive
man pero los had no no se sentir el in
yo yeah kiss until Olivia one year so
yes we ported the : cause you can't
assess a mean unibrow the kotel is our
concern s part from that is Yama's pero
también vamos which are a human la cosa
corn items from expert so you talked
about the music as well haven't you and
you compare it to the way you learn
pronunciation in school it is not just
they don't teach it well enough and then
emotions are involved in that when he
talks about notions about pulse grammar
and then people are not motivated plus
the content is not interesting at all
but apart from that yeah to answer your
question I think that language is music
in the real sense of the word it's just
a Mellie
if you people normally talk when they
talk about the speedy don't realize that
we have tolls every language of stones
has what stops as a pitch stress etc so
if you see a little bit like that you
know
music they they teach it literally they
teach it they can teach music how to
play music you can play and we have
vocal chords our instruments
we can teach people how to use their
local courts well this says language is
music and the real sense of the word no
it's not just something that you say
like that it's if you if you sit and if
you believe it you can learn accordingly
you know you can I think the language is
pronunciation and information there me
too difficult ears a lot of books
interesting books from a scientific
point of view they're made to complicate
it I think we in general I I have wait
and each pronunciation I teach
information pronunciation is just the
pronunciation of simple words all the
words are supposed to be produced
mechanically but then Latin languages
the aggregation of sounds which is
something different more complicated
that's the reason why a lot of people
have problems with intonation rather
than pronunciation also with parentheses
whether real problems in summation so I
agree this is out of here
I remember something that you were
telling me about relatives that you know
comments schools that we learned how to
house one word at a time but when we put
when people should have put the words
together doesn't sound good it almost
sounds like you know a voice translation
or something like that I go to the
school it's just not natural yeah yeah
it's because you know they're not talked
to after sentences like in Chinese this
is the glaring example of this they
teach people how to pronounce the single
films but then people cannot say
sentences they even when they do learn
well they still won't sound stiff
because they don't they're not talk to
say sentence playing the Chinese the
Chinese learn since they're a little
kids how to pronounce entire sentences
they learn I didn't learn law should or
should and then you know they learn it
accordingly so that's reason why it
could speak like natives and foreigners
it takes a long time and then a lot of
effort and a lot of them just give up
because I think the approach is ok
you've learned a lot about your
languages their sons or some other
languages their songs tell the truth I
perfected languages
this means that especially English might
have I think they have a large
vocabulary I listen to thousands of
songs and you know I wanted to
understand what they were talking about
they were singing so I went to look
through a script etc etc that I looked
up with words meaning of words
so yeah and unlike Richard we like
singing mourning me staying all the time
even in the shower everywhere so I heard
on the street - on the street the bar
the restaurant in the street in the
shower so that is a good way to I think
it's also for intonation because even if
seniors not the same thing as speaking
it's a different thing but it still
helps you know we got this to come like
singing there must be a connection I'm
sure there's a connection between even
pronunciation intonation and music and
something that also I think teachers
forget to talk about when it comes to
learning songs is that with the Sun so
not only do you learn vocabulary but
you're also learning the grammar and you
remember well if the song isn't correct
it is incorrect English whatever
language it is but you remember certain
grammatical forms and that definitely
helps me you know like one of my issues
with Portuguese is trying to remember
the mood of the subject evil or whatever
that doesn't existence in Spanish
doesn't exist
so I look for it it's not where I listen
for it in songs I try to understand okay
how is it that this is for what he said
one day you'll spoil it whether you your
vote
so that's that that's the kind of stuff
that I've been using right now and then
I haven't found in a spoken speech that
I'll be speaking and I can't think of a
word and I'll hear it in my head I'll
hear the song anyway another full song I
hear look at first and usually I don't
start breaking out in song in the middle
of a sentence maybe I will start soon
yeah depends of the dispense of the
environment but I'll hear the sámi my
head and then I'll say the word and so
you know you think that oh it's only for
children to listen to music no I mean
even for adults
I mean I'm using songs and one of the
examples that I give is that Russian was
my first language and I learned how to
read and write in Russian before I
learned how to read and write in English
but there was no alphabet song when I
was a kid for the Russian alphabet
there is I think there's no so even
though I can read and write in Russian I
don't remember the order of the alphabet
it's when I have to look for a word of
the Russian dictionary I have a lot of
trouble because I can't remember the
order they off of it and I have to look
at the first page of the alphabet and
see all the letters
whereas in English if you forget the
order of the alphabet you just start
singing ABC and it sounds quite silly
but here I am an adult
illiterate adult and I sometimes have to
sing the ABC song to remember
fantastic thank you very much it's a
really interesting insight into your
worlds and how you are like me as a
music tastes and the way you use it
combined to really enhance your your
learning say thanks for your time and
thanks very great few days in in the
posner